et c'est reparti huit mois que les
salles de sport sont fermées en france
la salle de sport un concept américain
des années 40 aux actifs collab eric
plouzeau américaine a prouvé si les
américains l'ont inventé les fronts
s'est longtemps porté dans les années 60
direction le club silhouette à paris où
ce qu'on pourrait appeler l' usine à
beauté tout un monde de machines atteint
ici la femme d'aujourd'hui qui veut
garder ou retrouver la silhouette idéale
cette fameuse silhouette qui donne tant
de soucis la machine et galbées les
jambes
la machine à affermir la poitrine la
machine à affiner les mollets et les
cuisses les femmes travaillent leur
silhouette idéale et les hommes ont de
la villette
on peut toucher santé cost être beaucoup
plus qu'avant
et à chaque décennie sa tendance dans
les années 70 les cours de gym collectif
ces personnes surprises au cours d'une
séance de culture physique ne sont pas
des athlètes se préparent en vue d'une
compétition
bien au contraire ils viennent là une ou
deux soirées par semaine dans le simple
but de garder la forme
mazel vous venez souvent ici faire de la
gymnastique et tous les vendredis deux
fois par semaine le lundi pendre touchés
oui régulièrement il ça fait deux ans
dont les années 80 c'est la découverte
de l'aérobic véronique et davina fou
transpirer les français
mais pas
mais là mot de passe et débarque avec
les années 90 le fitness ce phénomène
s'appelle le fitness aujourd'hui nous
sommes entrés dans l'ère du stretching
cardio training low impact ou bien step
autant de termes barbares qui signifie
faire de la gym intelligemment la
dernière étape c'est celle ci les années
2010 et les salles de sport low cost
depuis quelques euros suffisent pour se
modeler un corps de rêve en salle de
musculation 150 machines
le top de la technologie pour un prix
low cost
et tant pis si là aussi aucun prof n'est
présent qu'en vous assistez on peut pas
tout avoir à ce tarif-là low cost ou non
la salle de sport fait des adeptes
aujourd'hui en france il y à 4500 salle
de fitness et 7 millions de pratiquants
[Musique]